hello my name is philip schmidt and i am
technical lead at hugging face i'm
excited to be able to show you and mou
the new azure hacking phase and points
okay let's get started
in the demo we are going to create a new
azure hacking phase endpoint for text
classification hacking phase endpoints
are managed azure application powered by
machine learning we are currently in the
ui where we can create our endpoint
first we need to select our subscription
then our resource group
next we are going to select our region
in this case we are going to use east us
and define an endpoint name let's go
with distal
distal bird
as next we are going to select our model
from the heightened phase hub for this
we can go to filter
text classification
and then select one of the available
models we are going to use the distal
bird model which also fits our endpoint
name copy the model id and paste it into
our model id input field then we are
going to select our text classification
to cast
okay as next we are going to define an
application name
let's go with text distil
and then we need to provide a managed
resource group name you can go with
hugging face
this
our application managed resource group
holds all resources that are required to
create our hugging phase endpoint
after we have done that we can select
our compute in this case we are going to
use a cpu instance but you can also go
with a gpu instance the nice part about
hugging phase endpoints is that they are
going to deliver auto scaling out of the
box meaning we can select our min
instance card and our max instance card
we are going to do this for max with two
so we are going to be able to scale from
one to two instances and then we need to
provide our threshold we are going to
use requests per minute as our threshold
target and we are going to select 1000
this means that our endpoint will
receive requests and if we have an
average over 1000 requests over a period
for 5 minutes the endpoint will
automatically scale out and if the load
decreases the endpoint will also
automatically scale in again okay now
let's review and create
all our validation has passed we can
scroll down and then see again our
provided values we have our model id
with digital bird our task text
classification and the resource name we
have provided we can also see our
instance type and the auto scaling
configuration okay let's create
our endpoint will now be created this
will take a few minutes i will be back
when the endpoint or the deployment is
complete
our deployment is complete and we can
test our endpoint therefore we go to the
resource
to output where we can see our inference
uri our api authentication token and the
playground url we can use to test our
endpoint
here we have a widget where we can
immediately use
to run inference and code snippet
let's test it
the new
hugging
phase and points
are easy
to use
and we can see our model predicted the
correct sentiment for it we can also
copy the python snippet and execute it
for example in a jupyter notebook
here
you can also see that our model has
predicted our label correctly
i am philip and this was a quick look at
the new azure hugging phase endpoints
thank you